الى اخر تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
حيث اعلن الجيش الاوكراني تدميره 37
صاروخا من نوع كروز وتسعه وعشرين مسيره
هجوميه استهدفت البلاد اليله الماضيه وثق
فريق الجزيره لحظه اعتراض احد الاهداف في
سماء المدينه وافادت الاداره العسكريه في
كييف بان القوات الروسيه شنت هجوما لاسراب
من مسيرات شاهد المفخخه وصواريخ كروز من
قاذفات الاستراتيجيه فوق بحر قزوين
في مقاطعه اوديسا الجنوبيه البلاد افادت
الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه باسقاط
دفاعاتها الجويه عددا من المسيرات الروسيه
الهجوميه واكد المتحدث باسم الاداره
ان خطر الهجمات واسعه النطاق على المقاطعه
ما يزال قائما
تعرضت لمنطقه لهجوم بمسيارات من نوع شاهد
وقامت قوات الدفاع بتدمير الاهداف الجويه
للعدو وقد تسبب سقوط حطام مسيره في ميناء
اوديسا في اندلاع حريق وتمت السيطره عليه
فورا